what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
hope all of you guys had an amazing
Thanksgiving I know I did like I went
over to Binney a comic store his house
it had Thanksgiving with him it was
awesome Houston is Sarge an amazing cook
Houston's one of the editors that works
for Benny he's such an amazing chef like
he's a trained chef and he is so good at
cooking stuff I'm a pineapple
upside-down cake which turned out to be
amazing Houston's girlfriend Molly made
this super good cheese it like pecan
cheesecake for my cheesecake and then I
learned I learned about something called
Pike Hagen it's where you take pie and
cake and you put them together you
combine them into one dessert I've never
heard of it before
Pike Aiken is an amazing name I don't
know who thought of that name but that's
an awesome thing to call it anyway we
are doing our vs. videos I don't even
know if we have a day for this I think
the videos just get released on like a
day when I don't have anything else
planned which is fine by me because it
keeps you guys on your toes you never
know where you're gonna see one pop up
but in this video we are pitting a
Marvel character against a DC character
and we're taking the characters of
Deadpool vs. the Batman who lost now
this is gonna be kind of cool so if
you're not familiar with the Batman who
last he debuted as part of the Dark
Knight's mettle event that has pretty
much been spanning all of DC's entire
lineup of their top comics for like the
last few months and in dark nights metal
the Batman who last number one writer
James Tinian revealed the origin story
of the Batman who laughs which we're
gonna cover briefly as part of this
video but if you want the full story of
his origin and what happened in that
book I have a video explaining it in
depth
and you'll find that video down in the
description but basically the Batman who
laughs is the Bruce Wayne of earth- 22
who one day while he was hanging out
doing whatever it is a Batman dust was
pushed to his breaking point when the
Joker implemented one of his toys and
Batman actually ended up killing the
Joker now when the Joker died some of
the Joker toxin that was inside of his
body in fact he was kind of like this
doomsday device that if the Joker died
this violent strain of the toxin is
purified version of the Joker toxin
would leave his body and spread into
whoever killed them turning them into
the new Joker and allowing the Joker's
legacy to move on and so what we ended
up having was this character that had
the highly intelligent and organized
mind of Bruce Wayne combined with a
criminal insanity of the Joker and from
here we actually end up seeing Batman
murdering most of the bat family Dick
Grayson Barbara Gordon Jason Todd and
Tim Drake because he knows they'll be
the first ones to
notice a change in his demeanor and he
needs them out of the way from there he
goes on to take out most of the Justice
League now we don't see how he takes
them all out all we know is that he took
them out using weapons that they had
gained over the course of their careers
as superheroes and they'd stored in the
safety of the Justice League Watchtower
but probably the most screwed up part of
his origin story as he captures Superman
Superman's son in Lois Lane and then
exposes Superman and his son to black
kryptonite which drives them insane and
they kill Lois life it's pretty gruesome
and that's why it's so awesome it is an
amazing story so in order to determine
who would come out of this contest with
a victory we have to see what each
character is capable of now in the case
of the Batman who lost we have not
gotten a full picture of what his powers
and abilities are but since he is
essentially just Batman that's been
infected with the Joker toxin it can
stand a reason that he will be capable
of doing anything that Batman or the
Joker could do and what that means is
that technically the Batman who lost
doesn't actually have any superpowers
since neither Batman nor the Joker are
super-powered beings however that does
not mean by any stretch of the
imagination that he's not a formidable
threat as we seen Batman take down some
of the most powerful superheroes in the
DC Universe but what makes him
formidable is the same thing that makes
Batman a threat his intelligence which
lends itself to creating a highly
skilled detective his prowess as a
hand-to-hand combatant and his
astronomical wealth that allows him to
buy whatever he needs to take down his
enemies of course this has always come
with a caveat that there was a line that
Batman would not cross under any
circumstances but this all goes out the
window with a Batman who lost due to the
Joker toxin that's infected him so what
you get is basically someone who's going
to use his intellect and his wealth to
devise ways to create as much
destruction and kill as many people as
possible and so essentially it
transforms him and the smartest
wealthiest murderer that you can imagine
and we could only even attempt to wrap
our minds around the amount of damage
that he could cause with a virtually
inexhaustible stream of resources at his
disposal
this of course all assumes that he's
still on earth negative 22 and you know
in his own universe and so on and so
forth on the other side of the battle we
have Deadpool who's one of the deadliest
characters in the Marvel Universe so I
assume that everybody watching this
IDEO is familiar with Deadpool and if
you're not then my question is where
have you been like Deadpool has a movie
now he's been a super popular character
for quite some time whenever he's not
going out and doing whatever Deadpool
does he plays the role of an actor named
Ryan Reynolds he does all kinds of
things like he's a really really cool
guy but he's essentially a mercenary an
assassin named Wade Wilson with a highly
efficient healing factor that was given
to him as part of an experiment
conducted by the weapons Plus program a
clandestine military operation that
endeavored to create the ultimate super
weapon after failing to capture the
super-soldier formula that made Captain
America and then trying to bond the
healing factor of wool rain to other
people now as for Deadpool powers he
actually only has one which is this
healing factor but his healing factor is
one of the strongest if not the
strongest in Marvel Comics and allows
him to heal from seemingly 80 injury now
Deadpool survived gunshot wounds
stabbings even decapitation and
disintegration thanks to his powerful
healing factor so this begs the question
is it even possible to kill Deadpool
well the answer is unfortunately not
clear-cut Deadpool is not inherently
immortal that it is theoretically
possible for his healing factor to be
overcome in much the same way as
Wolverines healing factor does not make
him immortal due in large part to the
fact that the DNA from Wolverines
healing factor was used to basically
create Deadpool's healing factor now
before the Deadpool fans who don't read
his comics and only read Wikipedia start
coming out of the woodwork and talking
about New Orleans curves with
immortality that's true for a time in
Marvel comics Deadpool was placed under
a curse of immortality by Thanos who was
jealous of the affection shown to
Deadpool by mistress death and didn't
want the two of them to get together so
this is actually what we can most likely
attribute to some of the insane
instances of healing that we've seen
deadpool undergo in the comics he
literally couldn't die so things that
would normally have just been too much
for his healing factor did not actually
kill him due to Thanos his curse what
Wikipedia will not tell you is that in
Deadpool vs. Thanos number one we
actually see the Thanos has a desire to
kill Deadpool which prompts him to lift
the curse of immortality
Thanos does end up killing Deadpool but
then he resurrects him later on because
he needs us help to track down mistress
death who is basically vanished now for
the purposes of this battle we're going
to assume that Deadpool is not immortal
but instead just possesses a highly
efficient healing
like he did before he was given the
curse of immortality but when Wayne
Deadpool's chances in this battle we
also have to take into consideration
Deadpool's other skills which include
being an expert in hand-to-hand combat
swordsmanship and marksmanship all owing
to Deadpool's extensive training as an
assassin so the question is who would
win in this battle well the answer is it
depends I know this is kind of a non
answer but I'll explain I'll explain you
guys what I mean if the scenario is
these two characters meeting each other
sight unseen and just fighting I'd give
the nod to Deadpool he not only is going
to be able to match the Batman who lasts
as a fighter but his healing factor will
allow him to withstand any damage that
Batman's able to do to him so even if
Batman is a more skilled combatant which
is debatable eventually his body will
tire and the damage that's being dealt
to him will accumulate and he'll succumb
to his injuries granting Deadpool the
victory but this would not be a video
about Batman if we didn't mention prep
time and while that's something I joke
about a lot because it is a joke I do
think that in this scenario it would
tilt the balance in Batman's favor the
reason I say that is that if there is
something out there the Batman who
laughs can use to kill Deadpool we can
be sure that a he'll figure it out
because he still possesses Bruce Wayne's
detective skills and intelligence be
he'll spend any amount of money or take
whatever other means he needs to acquire
it see he won't hesitate to use it on
Deadpool and B he's Batman so the
question is is anything like this exists
well if you go back and watch my video
on how to kill Deadpool and my video on
how to kill Wolverine we discussed a few
things in the Marvel Universe that can
counteract their healing factors one of
those things was carbonadium which is an
unstable version of adamantium
engineered by the Soviets which has the
property of suppressing healing factors
of Wolverine and by extension Deadpool
another artifact within the Marvel
Universe that's effective at negating
healing factors in their entirety is the
Muramasa blade which was forged using a
piece of Wolverine soul and can
effectively wipe out his healing factor
in his entirety if it's used on him
so his Batman had prepped time to
prepare for this battle with Deadpool he
could theoretically learn of the
existence of the Muramasa blade acquire
it cut Deadpool with it and wipe out his
healing factor and use any of the rest
of his vast arsenal of weapons to take
Deadpool out but yeah
that's how I kind of see this going down
that's my interpretation of Deadpool vs.
the Batman who lasts I mean I'll be
honest I think a comic where Deadpool
encounters a Batman who laughs would be
amazing not only would the battle be
brutal but it would be hilarious
as well I could just see Deadpool like
asking about asking the Batman who
laughs how he can see with spikes over
his eyes and imagining how a Batman
Joker hybrid would respond to Deadpool's
wisecracks which honestly I don't know
how that would go down but it's
something I definitely want to read
about I really want to see that I really
want to see that comic though with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
cork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]